هذه القافله المكونه من خمسه اسعافات
وباص دخلت الى شمال قطاع غزه بتنسيق مع
قوات الاحتلال تنسيق مسبق ومنسق وبخري طه
منظمه لكن قوات الاحتلال قامت باطلاق
النار المباشر على هذه القافله مما اوقعت
شهيد واصابت من طواقم الهلال الاحمر على
الرغم من ذلك ان هذا اطلاق النار هذا شكل
خطرا كبيرا على حياه الكثير من الا
وشكل خطرا كبيرا على حياه الكثير من
المرضى الذين تواجدوا داخل هذه القافله تم
انتقال هذه القافله من مستشفى المعمداني
الى مستشفى الشفاء لاجلاء مزيدا من
الاصابات والجرحى لكن قوات الاحتلال خلال
مغادرتها مستشفى الشفاء قامت باطلاق النار
الكثيف تم اطلاق النار مباشره مباشره بهدف
القتل يعني مش تحذيري في الارض مباشر على
السائقين وعلى المسعفين على الطاقم
الامامي التنسيق سيق معه علم يعني الصليب
او الجهه المنسقه اللي وجهتنا على درايه
كامله على درايه كامله بطريقنا طب ليش
الاستهداف المباشر لاكثر من سياره انا
السؤال بساله احنا جينا اكثر من مره انا
دخلت التنسيق تسع مرات تسع مرات ما فيش
علينا شيء وضمن ضمن الاطار المحدد اللي
بدونا اياه بنمشي وهي سياره الشهيد الشهيد
طلق مباشر وهذا سياره
الشهيد طلق مباشر طلق
مباشر
الان مين كان السيارات كانوا اطفال اطفال
وامهات فقط رجال ما كانش معنا اطفال
مبتوره اقدامها اطفال مريض السرطان احنا
جايين
لاجلاء المصابين همه
انسانيه من مستشفيات غزه
لعدم وجود
الامكانيات
اللازمه لمتابعتهم واجلاهم الى اللي هو
المنطقه الجنوبيه لكن الجيش الاسرائيلي لم
يتمم هذه عمليه الاجلاء
بسبب الاعتداء والانتهاك الذي قام به
علينا كطقم طبيه كطقم
انسانيه فادى الى اصابتي وادى الى استشهاد
احد الاخوه الزملاء تواصل قوات الاحتلال
استهداف كافه الطواقم العامله في الميدان
حتى وصل الخطر الى طواقم الهلال الاحمر
مما ادى الى ارتقاء شهيد وعدد من الاصابات
خلال مهمتهم الانسانيه شمال قطاع غزه
اسماعيل الغول
الجزيره مستشفى الشفاء مدينه غزه